[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm Nick going welcome to the
emmanuel center here in the heart of
London for this intelligence squared
debate is this the moment to call the
giant tech companies to account in the
space of just 10 years Google Apple
Facebook Amazon and Microsoft all
American companies have become the
biggest companies by value on our planet
their digital ingenuity their innovation
their risk-taking
have transformed our lives beyond
recognition but have companies born in
garages or university dormitories
accrued a level of extraordinary
financial and technological power that
threatens us all in multiple ways they
control our data they know an enormous
about about us and what we do they exert
increasing dominance over how we behave
increasing numbers of us fear they walk
the way we think and our democratic
discourse with so much uncontrolled
digital power our debate it's time to
break up the tech giants we have an
excellent panel for you here arguing for
the motion rana fara
welcome whose global business columnist
at the Financial Times and Luke Johnson
one of Britain's best-known and most
successful entrepreneurs against the
motion pinna Ackman who is an expert in
EU competition law at the University of
Leeds in the past
she's done research commissioned by
Google and Elizabeth Linda former head
of Facebook's politics and government
division for Europe the Middle East and
Africa ladies and gentlemen your
speakers for this debate
[Applause]
well shortly you will hear from the four
panelists too for the motion to against
I will then throw up in the debate to
the floor the audience was asked to vote
on the motion before the debate and
you'll know which way you're thinking
now just before the vote at the end of
the debate now the opening statements
from the four panelists speaking first
for the motion it's time to break up the
tech giant's Rana for ooh-ha who is
global business columnist and an
associate editor at the Financial Times
based in New York she's also a global
economic analyst for CNN the floor is
yours thanks to all of you for being
here this is a cognitive crisis but this
is also a political crisis and an
economic crisis let me address the
politics first there is now a large body
of evidence to show that social media
and the largest platform companies were
very much involved in the Russian
manipulation of the US elections and
this is the case with other countries as
well now these firms may or may not have
known the way in which their
technologies were being used but they
were nonetheless part of this these
technologies have used in emerging
markets like Myanmar for example to
prepare populations for genocide this
business model this hyper targeted
advertising business model which is
meant to collect data about all of us
and then use it to deliver products
services content news fake or otherwise
based on your own existing preferences
is a business model that has caused this
crisis it creates the filter bubbles
reinforcing our own existing opinions
that has been responsible for the
populism and we've seen throughout
Europe has been responsible in part for
brexit for the populism that we see in
the US for the incredibly polarized
politics that we have now and in fact if
you overlay usage of news on platform
technologies on the largest platform
sites like Facebook Google Netflix
Amazon etc you will see patterns about
voting and you will see that these
platform technologies actually push
extreme opinions extreme political views
it's interesting to me actually when I
look at Mark Zuckerberg the CEO of
Facebook his latest attempts to try and
fix the problem which are long overdue
and quite poor in my opinion he's
encouraging users to go away from news
sites and towards family and friends but
family and friends are exactly the
filter bubbles that create and reinforce
our existing biases these problems have
not been fixed huge political issues
these companies are also monopolist
let's make no mistake about it 80% of
corporate wealth in America now lives in
10% of firms these are the IP rich firms
most of them in California the largest
of which are the fangs Facebook Amazon
Netflix Google these are the largest
platform firms they are controlling
vastly more wealth than any other
company out there they are driving the
markets not just in the US but in all
other countries this is where wealth
lives now the network effects that allow
these firms to expand exponentially are
also part of the monopoly problem
network effects allow these firms to
gobble up market share more data more
users means more advertising revenue for
them that's part of the monopoly power
but these effects also allow them to
exhibit real anti-competitive behaviors
there are court cases going on as you
all well know in the EU about these
behaviors companies can get as big as
they want but as long as their products
and services are going down in price
there's no problem but we are living in
a new digital world now the products and
services that these firms offer are free
or cheap we think they're free we're
actually paying with our data our data
is their oil our data is the most
valuable commodity we have so we have no
idea how much value is going out the
window now there's an idea that well
these services are working so well how
could we possibly break them up but
let's go back and look at history in the
1920s with the railroads in the 1940s
and 50s
with the oil companies in the 1980s with
the telecoms companies there were
breakups there were checks on the power
of monopolies companies and guess what
growth afterwards was higher the number
of firms being started was higher wealth
was more equally shared breaking up
firms isn't a recipe for degrading
products and services it's actually a
recipe for innovation and I also look at
someone that thinks about capitalism and
how it's supposed to work I look at what
Adam Smith the father of modern
capitalism would have said about these
markets he believed that we needed three
things for markets to work properly
equal access to data transparency of
pricing of what is being exchanged and a
shared moral framework guess what when
you're using these technologies today
you have none of that big text should be
broken up thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
rather flu thank you very much indeed
for that opening statement for the
motion now let's go to the first voice
against the motion to peanut admin who
is professor of law at the University of
Leeds where she's also the director of
the Centre for business law and practice
be now the floor is yours
[Applause]
good evening on the 2nd of March 1998
the Fortune magazine announced the
winner of the search engine wars in the
following words once upon a time Yahoo
was an internet search site with
mediocre technology now it has a market
cap of 2.8 billion dollars some people
say it's the next America Online unquote
indeed six months later a company called
Google was born in order to predict hey
Steve that tech giant should be broken
up our opponents tonight meet the common
sea of three things first that the
technology market is not a competitive
one second that the tech giant's have
engaged in conduct that disrupts the
competitive process and ultimately harms
consumers third that breaking them up is
a necessary and proportionate reaction
to the harm that they have identified
which they won't have in fact they will
not be able to prove any of these
because there is no real-world evidence
to support any such claim that the tech
giant's should be broken up let's start
with the first thing that they need to
prove namely that the technology market
is not a competitive one that the tech
giant's are so big that they do not face
competition from anyone anymore
they are unshakeable this is blatantly
not true
AOL and Yahoo failed because they could
not keep up with the pace of innovation
to deliver better and even better
products and services to consumers
Google Amazon Facebook and others can
also fail if they fall into the same
trap in fast-moving technology markets
no company is too big to fail no one is
replaceable and it is that existential
threat the threat of competition from
those more innovative and better than
themselves that keep these tech giants
on their toes Narada has said technology
startups have gone
but 1.8 million technology startups are
still launched every year we only need
to think about successful startups like
uber Netflix experience and Spotify to
realize that competition is everywhere
we don't just use Google to search for a
product by we use Amazon and eBay and
online retailers the second point that
our opponents need to prove to convince
you that the tech giant should be broken
up is that these tech giants have
engaged in conduct that disrupts the
competitive process and ultimately harms
consumers it's not the size that matters
no modern competition law in the world
renders it unlawful to have even a
monopoly and let's not forget these
companies are not monopolies unlike what
Rana says because monopoly means a
single seller what the tech giant's do
in real life is quite the opposite of
harming consumers the back big tech
companies provide us with an endless
list of free services which make our
lives easier and more enjoyable in ways
we couldn't even imagine where possible
every year these companies provide 280
billion dollars worth of free services
to Americans and Europeans none of these
tech companies we're talking about today
or their products are essential or
indispensable people around the world
can and do live it at them all the time
therefore we cannot compare them to
utilities like water gas and electricity
and ask for them to be broken up let's
remind ourselves of the motion the
motion is to break up the tech giants
breaking up a company is the nuclear
option as you will see clearly by the
end of this evening the cause for
breaking the tech giants up are driven
not by real-world evidence of any
wrongdoing but I fear fear of the big
and fear of the unknown let's remember
for a second who these companies we're
talking about breaking up are all of the
big five we're going to talk about today
are in the top 10 of the world's most
admired company
there's some of the world's biggest
spenders on research and development
with Amazon leading the world they're
not good because they're big they're big
because they're good and what do our
opponents want to do with some of the
world's most successful companies in
history they want to break them up this
house should vote against the motion
thank you
[Music]
deena Rockmond with the first voice
against the motion with that very clear
gauntlet laid down to those proposing
the motion for breakup saying they are
big because they are good Luke Johnson
one of Britain's most successful
entrepreneurs former chairman of Channel
4 television here in the United Kingdom
the floor is yours
I think the tech giant should be broken
up because they are bad for society bad
for the creative community bad for
Britain bad for jobs bad for government
finances bad for people and bad for the
reputation of business I'm not the only
capitalists who think the tech giant's
are dangerous for example perhaps the
world's best no management guru Tom
Peters author of in search of excellent
wrote earlier this month a few billion
bucks of Zuckerberg in philanthropy does
not offset the catastrophic human damage
caused by his life desiccating invention
already Google and Facebook have 20% of
the world's entire global ad spend and
over 100 billion of advertising revenues
into 2016 almost three-quarters of all
online advertising unfortunately Google
has a higher market share of online
search in Britain virtually any other
market over 85% I call that a monopoly
they operate close to a monopoly here
and in much of Europe the EU competition
watchdog found them guilty of skewing
search results in their favor in their
own shopping services in breach of
antitrust rules last year they find them
2.4 billion euros for illegal
monopolistic behavior large is such fine
ever levied by the EU the EU has not
come to their decision to find Google
quickly or likely and the size of the
fine reflects the severe nature of the
crime and this is despite the
considerable amount of money the tech
giant's spend on lobbying here in the US
the duopoly in digital advertising is
merely the start of the problem Google
in particular is a notorious free rider
on Britain's film TV publishing and
music industries
Facebook has a similar parasitic model
both Facebook and Google are
industrial-scale corpora copyright
infringers and have no respect for
intellectual property saving course
their own they have huge quantities of
pirated material on their site such as
YouTube and are unbelievably lacks about
taking it down
unfortunately the traditional news and
content producers are generally the only
ones being properly regulated and many
are seeing their business model
destroyed by Google and Facebook if the
newspapers a new brought news
broadcasters go bankrupt then who will
report accurately and apply resource to
holding power to account in a
responsible way not Facebook and Google
they have each contributed heavily to
the rise of fake news and the damage it
has done to civic life their robotic
business models rely on algorithms and
have minimal human intervention great
for their profit margins but to disaster
for quality of information and
humanity's values politicians think
supporting the likes of Google and
Facebook is supporting innovation this
is a myth these giant firms are
oligopoly which suffocate
entrepreneurship by buying up any new
players to suffocate competition they've
bought Instagram whatsapp YouTube and
cents and many others Britain is easily
Google's second largest market over 6
billion a year of revenue derived from
British consumers it makes group net
profit margins of at least 25% which
probably means it's extracting at least
1.5 billion pounds of net profit in cash
a year from Britain then it claims to
make so little profit here it paid just
130 million pounds in corporation tax
for ten years of unpaid meant under
payments if it had paid corporation tax
at the standard 20 percent rate then the
tax it owed would have been 10 times the
amount it actually paid the tech giant's
are strict mining are creative and
cultural industries and undermining
democracy thanks to the rise of the
smartphone they've been running massive
social and psychological experiments on
their users without the users even
realising quite what's happening
addiction to Facebook YouTube Instagram
and so forth has a huge human cost
citizens have surrendered their personal
data for nothing the tech giant's are
exploiting the public's poor
understanding of software to destroy
markets and almost enslave citizens
while creating few jobs paying a
fraction of the tax they should and
generating no new creative content we
need a Teddy Roosevelt to see the threat
lead the charge break up these new tech
vampire squids in order to offer choice
and force more ethical behavior I ask
you to vote in favor of the resolution
thank
Luke Johnson thank you very much indeed
with it's clear bad bad bad bad bad I
didn't hear a good there 85% is a
monopoly arrogance is breathtaking and
they're above legislation the heart of
the argument from this side proposing
the motion now the second voice against
the motion
Elizabeth Linda welcome founder and
former head of Facebook's politics and
government division for Europe the
Middle East and Africa previously
working on politics and communications
at YouTube the year it was acquired by
Google now CEO of the conversational
century a global advisory movement
Elizabeth Linda the floor is yours
[Music]
well I spent eight years at Facebook
from 2008 to 2016 by the time I left the
company about a year and a half ago I
had been at Facebook longer than 99.2%
of employees at the time and you know
you see a lot in eight years at a
company that's growing as quickly as
Facebook I arrived in that magical time
when everyone was realizing that
Facebook was becoming more than a place
where friends and family were sharing
vacation photos and the odd bit of
gossip it was actually starting to have
a real and serious impact on the world
and I had a fascinating portfolio
working with civil society leaders to
help them understand this space and in
order to reach these people I partnered
with an organization called tech camp
and we would go around from Kazakhstan
to Morocco Israel Palestine Iraq
Lithuania to work with civil society
leaders and train them up on how to make
the most of the new tools that were
available to them to get their messages
heard to see their ideas to make a
positive difference in the world
for everyone else Facebook is a service
it's a series of products and features
and we wish each other happy birthday
and we share photos and that's all
wonderful but for them Facebook was the
promise it's that new global platform
where they can connect in a completely
different way most of us in this room
don't even understand to change the
world now that changes the conversation
that means that sitting wherever we're
sitting in our in our rooms or in London
we actually have to think about the
global community we're talking about
because the decisions we make here are
going to have a
huge impact on people that don't
actually have a voice in this kind of
debate this debate is also incredibly
dangerous because it's so alluring and
it's so fashionable right now to blame
everything on names of companies that
people reading the news have heard about
and this is really harmful because what
it does is it masks what's really going
on in our societies the tech sector the
tech companies these platforms put up a
mirror to the real world if anything we
understand the real world better because
we encounter it we see it that might be
a slightly scary thing it's also a very
good thing and if these last few months
have actually flared up some of the
challenges the deep challenges of this
space the threats in the space the dark
and sinister corners which do exist will
they exist in the real world - we have a
moment in time here to channel them for
the better or not
and finally it's disappointing that
we're having a conversation about
breaking up the so-called tech giants
disappointing because it fails to
understand the true potential of the
network effect networks only work to
their maximum potential when they're big
that's the whole promise of this space
the bigger they are the more people who
are connecting the more you're actually
finding these communities emerge where
people from far different countries and
backgrounds are connecting and saying
hey we both have the same problem let's
go out and fix it unless we actually
allow these networks to grow we don't
allow them to reach any semblance of
potential that would be such a failure
to actually see this era through and
it's our time that gets to decide how
this story ends thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much indeed with that
very clear alert that this is a
misleading dangerous and disappointing
debate now in a moment I'm going to come
to you and ask you for your thoughts
your points but before I do that I'm
gonna reveal now what you were thinking
when you came in more than a third of
you hadn't made up your mind at that
point
but the pre debate vote at the moment is
showing for the motion 39% against the
motion
24% so let me come to the floor
stand up please tell me which way you're
gonna vote for or into the motion right
let me go to number 3 first of all I'm
against the motion and I have a question
for the people who are for the motion
could you like give a concrete example
of one or two companies and how you
would split them up would you split them
up by sector or like by a vertical or
try to split them up by country or all
right how can you split up the companies
that's the question and we'll come to
you in a moment number 4 please I'm
against the motion and I think that the
proponents gave the game away on this
when Rana started criticizing the big
tech companies for bringing disasters
like brexit like from like worst of all
populist parties in Europe because what
we're seeing here is the death rattle of
the old progressive monopolies this was
a way of thinking which dominated
society for many many years and now
people are being empowered by technology
to disagree and all the criticism of
these big tech companies is coming from
the left the progressives of politics
who are fed up with their monopoly being
taken away
thank you down here at the front please
on microphone number one
hi I'm formation and I was just
wondering with you talking about the
dreams and how the fact that Facebook is
made to sort of unleash all those dreams
but you're sort of giving the impression
that Facebook is this philanthropy
organization I ask you how does Facebook
make make money what is where is its
business model and surely that gives it
away as well okay thank you Elizabeth
Lindroth come to you in a moment but
that first question about how do you
split the companies each company would
have to be looked at in a different way
but but let me just have it can be done
it has been done it's been done by any
other number of industries in the past
they fight against data privacy they
fight any kind of less draconian
solution that has been proposed they
fight against so I fear frankly that
there is going to have to be really
tough regulatory measures like a breakup
to actually shift their power and by the
way these firms have bought much of
Washington tech is the number two
lobbying power in Washington right now
so sadly I fear that the measures are
going to have to be tough to bring these
firms to heel P directly cabinets be
done it's an expert in competition law
but if I could just pick up that last
point in terms of talking about breaking
up the number to lobby ur so you're
admitting there's even a bigger Lobby er
than the tech giant so why aren't we
talking about breaking them up if we're
worried about political political power
surely we should also be talking about
the finance industry the health industry
energy industry where we also see giants
we cannot compare the so-called tech
giants to the monopolies which provided
water gas electricity tech companies are
nothing like natural monopolies there is
there's competition for a start on both
sides of the market so that's the
crucial distinction it's so breaking
them up good before it starts so much
more complicated than breaking up in any
other company in another industry
Elizabeth Linda that particular question
there about money yeah the whole point
of so many of these services is anybody
no matter where they live can use them
and you are served ads when you're using
these these products as a you know very
innocuous way of actually paying for
these services on the back end but I
think it's an important point because to
flag the point about not really
understanding how it is that you can
build an idea on a platform
is really a reflective of the country
that we're in right now we're having
this conversation in a country that
benefits from rule of law that benefits
from freedoms of speech in so many
countries where people are using these
services they're using these services as
the only way to have safe conversations
that otherwise would be illegal in their
jurisdictions
it's hugely important that this entire
community works hard to keep these
services up and available for those
people Luke Johnson can I just come come
to you you used bad bad bad bad I lost
count actually at the beginning of your
remarks do you see anything good in them
given what we've just heard from those
against the motion I think if they
weren't so monopolistic if they were not
well they're fantasizing 85% of a market
is a monopoly in search Google is
monopoly percent share Google has in
search Amazon takes 50% of all
e-commerce sales abuse of created
content it's their infringement of
copyright it's their aggression towards
taxation it's their deliberate addiction
of users that I think is so unhealthy
and all the business about you know
Africa and things he's a sort of
distraction it's a joke
Pina let let let's be clear you're a
professor of competition law is 85%
a monopoly just made a mistake they have
just treated a two sided market as a one
sided market and this is where the
crucial differences there is no search
engine market because when you say the
market is for search engines you're
completely ignoring the side of the
market which provides the revenue for
that search website to run if your
depression is a one eighty five percent
they say on that side is a monopoly the
definition of a monopoly is a single
seller
it's from it has a dominant position and
as I said having a dominant position is
not unlawful
it's the eby's of that position through
conduct that distorts competition and in
modern competition laws we understand
that distortion to mean you're harming
consumers either through increased
prices or lowered quality that's what's
unlawful not having a monopoly it's the
use of the power to exploit that power
if I may jump in for a moment this is
actually a crucial point and it links
together two points we've just heard the
entire definition of monopolies which by
the way varies amongst academics and
from country to country is in question
here these firms relative to their
market crack cap create vastly fewer
jobs than in the past
they are anti-competitive in any number
of ways they are patent infringes but
going to the point and this is crucial
to tie these two things together the
advertising model is what's that
question here when you use these
supposedly free services free isn't free
you pay with your data Facebook knows if
you're depressed what you do online
where you work what your political
beliefs are and they then
sell that information to the highest
bidder don't kid yourself
day three is not free and they sell it
to third-party advertisers that you have
no idea who they are
alright I should tell you we did invite
Google we did invite Google onto this
panel but they declined but let me just
let me just correct let's say it's it's
easy to poke holes on the outside I'm
the only person in this panel who
actually has spent time on the inside of
these companies but you know they're in
the moment no but what you have to
understand is that in the early days
growth this is key
these are entrepreneurs that's how the
entrepreneurs minds thinks look at the
kind of jobs right now that these
companies are pioneering it directors of
compassion research you know who else is
thinking about how it is that they can
transform their businesses into ways
that as Mark Zuckerberg has said are
actually healthy unproductive to the
quality of our lives this is a changing
space we can't get stuck in five years
ago time this space is so dynamic we
have to be talking about 2018 Elizabeth
thank you right let me get some more
views please a lady down at the front
here please and Elizabeth Linda you you
said that the you felt one of the
benefits was that these platforms are
there to make the world a better place I
I read about terrorism videos sexism
Vizio sex abuse videos murder videos
being put up on and not being taken down
when they're when they're reported and I
put it to you that they're not good
stewards because of these things that
they do not do that they should do thank
you
we have a view here from the next
generation who've grown up with all this
stuff please I are you for or against I
am against the breakup but for
legislation surely breaking up the tech
giants will form a power vacuum which
will be filled by the competitors of
performance and competitors of today is
breaking out the tech giants the best
way to remedy the problems or was it
applied for time thank you
please over there I was undecided and
now I'm definitely against mr. Johnson
and is there anything good about these
companies because I've been on your
website and you sell your book on Amazon
and iTunes
[Applause]
do you sell them well Luke or are you
get your masters any would have through
a traditional publisher hey if this is
about Luke Johnson in his books are you
withdrawing your books I don't sell them
the publisher does and you know what I
miss traditional book shops
I think they mattered they were more
than just retailers they were culture do
you reckon you sell more books online
that he's doing book shops probably now
and I should come back to the point are
they all bad the truth is once upon a
time perhaps they were very good they
were innovative you talked about the
early days and I'm sure in the early
days Facebook was a real nice place but
you know what happens is companies sell
out on size and profits become dominant
and that is what has happened at
Facebook and Google and others and size
has its own perils and these companies
are too big and too powerful and they
don't care and with success becomes
arrogance and hubris and let's hope
there's some Nemesis that follows right
great let's get more views from the
audience please right at the back number
three there is something to be said for
these companies many of them being
natural monopolies we want to be able to
go online and share some of these things
with as many people as possible there's
a natural tendency for that but that is
likely to be washed away in the way in
which so many waves of Technology have
been over the last 3040 years we once
thought Microsoft would never be
dislodged as the major technology player
because it owned applications of things
we don't even do anymore monopolies die
because whole waves of Technology passes
by not because other people have to come
along and disrupt them and we can see
now that that is going to happen to us
all we can imagine how that's going to
happen to some of these players and if
the case therefore is not that the
monopoly is evil but their behavior is
evil we shouldn't be talking about tech
giants we should be talking about
individual companies who need to be
taken over and wrapped over the knuckles
made to pay more tax made to be honest
about what they're doing and Google in
particular should be in our crosshairs
we know you're just nodding your head
there
why that's exactly the point we
shouldn't be talking about tech joints
in general we shouldn't we talk about
markets what we take our markets we
should be talking about specific conduct
in a specifically defined market and
whether that specific conduct actually
distorts competition on that market and
that's what the law actually does and
tax and other issues they're not part of
this law which is competition or they're
different policies in here tax policy
have labor policy higher data protection
policy and by all means use all of them
they should be subject to the law as
much as anyone else but breaking them up
although it is an option in the toolkit
it is really the nuclear option and if I
could just correct one point because I
think it's important
Ronna said that Facebook sells your data
if you go to Facebook's Privacy Policy
and Google's they do not sell your data
they explicitly state that they use the
data to match you to advertisers who
have relevant advertisements to show to
you as consumers and type
the Johnson who's ever read Google or
Facebooks privacy policy
you know those forms you have to design
before you use them they're designed so
no one ever reads them so you take all
their policies wholesale and that's the
way they operate they are ruthless they
are arrogant and they want to control
then we get more views please we're
burning short of time I want you to be
brief and as sharp as you can be over
there please first I was wondering those
that are for this motion do you believe
that the public is too stupid to decide
themselves public too stupid sit on that
one for a moment who's got the
microphone over there I'm against the
motion I have a question for the fall
camp why is increased regulation not
enough why do you need to go so far as
breaking up the tech giant's all right
thank you right increased regulation is
not enough what's your answer I would
love to believe that there was a kinder
gentler solution but I covered the
financial markets I'm covering tech now
these folks play hard let me put that
other point which came out there that
the public is too stupid to decide for
themselves the public is certainly not
stupid and his comments suggest that the
public hadn't see through all the
rhetoric and ad hominem coming from the
other side that they don't actually have
any evidence to give to you it's all
speculation and fear and the public is
not stupid and although the public
always vote with their feet actually if
they're still using these platforms if
they're still joining in their millions
and billions but maybe the public have
it's right maybe they actually like
these products and services so how come
we come and intervene you know with the
nuclear option of breaking them up I
just thought the public is too stupid
Luke I don't think the public is stupid
at all but I'm not sure that of the tens
of millions billions of users of things
like Facebook do they really understand
her
did they actually the economic the
public almost people don't actually
understand most people commenting on
these services don't actually understand
how they work do they be exploited is
their ignorance being exploited that's
one of the big no I actually think it's
the I think it's the opposite I think
that primarily the reason these
companies get such a bad rap is because
most people talking about them don't get
it 44% of people using social media in
America see news from the right and the
left that's twice the rate of non social
media users so this whole filter bubble
cons discussion is I think way overblown
in reality all right one final point for
Elizabeth not this is about your former
employers when you see Mark Zuckerberg
on the 4th of January in his New Year's
message to everyone inside and outside
the company say we currently make too
many errors enforcing our policies and
preventing misuse of our tools are they
getting their comeuppance now are they
realizing too late the mistakes they
should have seen coming down the track I
don't think it's too late I think that
it's a really good time to be having
this conversation the fact that these
companies actually recognize as you do
the challenges the fact that these
companies are addressing as you are
these challenges is going to lead us all
into a much better place Luke Johnson
and Ron Rizzo that point about what Mark
Zuckerberg himself has chosen to say we
currently make too many errors enforcing
our policies and preventing misuse of
our tools well it's good to see that the
management and owners are recognizing
that the business is a flawed I worry
that it's too little too late and that
it isn't going to make enough difference
to the what I believe to be very
significant damage done by companies
like Facebook and his remedies are off I
mean pushing people towards friends and
family rather than to true news is
actually going to increase the filter
bubble problem well but these kinds of
conversations or conversations that are
happening in our everyday lives they
should be happening online what about
that issue pinna of the fact that many
of these tech
I did not see the connection between
their algorithms selling adverts and
some of the vile videos which were being
posted the fact is it took the public
and also the advertisers to say we want
nothing to do with that newspapers like
The Times ad because they spend on
content and have journalists there were
a lot of advertisers as well who said we
want nothing to do with this in other
words they were deciding this was
unacceptable and they took immediate
action I mean they should've seen it
coming the point here is Google for
example changes apparently its
algorithms about 600 times a year to
stay on top of all of that but if they
still fail to do of course they should
take action to remedy it and from what
you can read in the press in reaction
for example of the recent Times
investigation they have taken action
pretty much immediately I mean there is
only so much they can do to stay on top
of course they should be subject to the
rules on data protection on not you know
promoting illegal content and so on no
one is saying that this should continue
but essentially how much the intervene
is the question and in what way they
intervene are the current regulations
sufficient or do we have a failure which
suggests we should take a drastic action
like breaking up but like the point that
was made earlier you break them up today
other companies can reach that same size
because of the network effects they get
big when they're successful so it's not
the size that we should be focusing on
Lutron's and I just have to put it to
you given what you said right at the
beginning of your remarks is there
anything good that you would like to
describe coming from the tech giants
well of course they have been in the
past innovative and only in the past in
the past I think they have become giant
sucking sound of money being Hoover duck
from all over the world going into
Silicon Valley and that dominates now
their every behavior and if you look for
example at how the simple google page
has changed over the years the amount of
space devoted to actual natural search
is a fraction of what it used to be
because the rest is all clutter that is
earning them money and that shows how
non-natural there
surges look at the actual product itself
it always happens I'm afraid when you
get a giant monopoly but then you can
use a different search engine well no
one does because they have a monopoly
network some reason I do because I
dislike what do you use I use Bing
only because it's not Google and there
are some rumors being has been stealing
there were copying Google's results for
years one final thought he's a Brit this
is not fair in debates where we have a
disadvantage by being foreigners I want
to ask you one final question given the
exponential change coming from
algorithms and artificial intelligence
what do you predict will be on your side
of the house will be the impact of this
particularly when it's expected to not
just destroy jobs but also create a vast
number of jobs which we don't even know
about at the moment well I worry that we
don't know about the jobs that are going
to be created but we have an idea of
some of the jobs are going to be
destroyed and that worries me a lot
you know I hope that there are
sufficient ingenuity and entrepreneurs
out there that there will be new jobs
because otherwise that will lead to
misery in trouble I think it's a process
it's gonna have to be managed well by
governments I think we're in for five
years of big time job disruption that's
moving higher and higher up the food
chain and it's interesting I was
actually in Silicon Valley I spend a lot
of time there in Silicon Valley last
week talking to Marc Benioff the CEO of
Salesforce they're doing a lot around AI
and you know he told me said it's time
for more regulation we probably need an
FDA of tech because this stuff is
affecting us in ways we don't understand
okay right at that point let me just
give you the result of the ballot and I
need to to tell you what you were
thinking remind you what you were
thinking when you came in here at the
start of the debate 37% more than a
third of you were undecided and the vote
then which was taken at the door was for
the motion 39% the breakup of the Giants
against was 24% now only two percent are
undecided most of you have made up your
mind which is great that means the
debate has worked but I have to tell you
that compared to 39%
for the motion it's now 46% for the
motion but 52% against
[Applause]
[Music]
so even allowing for undecided a
significant move from that side to this
side so I declared the motion defeated
by 52% to 46%
[Applause]
so quickly congratulations to this side
that side didn't manage to hold your
support thanks to all four speakers the
audience here at the Emmanuel Center
here in London a what was a fascinating
debate my thanks as well to intelligence
squared for making it possible goodbye
from in Mena cowing and everyone here in
London bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]